The last lesson introduced
the concept of arguments.
This time around we're
going to distinguish now
noun roles from down cases.
If you're not clear on down cases,
take a look at the lesson on nouns in
the introduction to the grammar of words.
Let's go back to the example I gave
it to him from the last lesson.
The verb give takes a giver.
A given that is something that is given
and to give [inaudible] someone who's
the recipient of what is given.
We end up with three roles,
almost like performances that
those nouns play more specifically,
they're themed or thematic roles.
Those thematic roles are giver,
given and Givi.
Those three roles become available
because we opted to use the verb give,
so the verb give dictates three roles.
Other verbs have roles to see,
has a seer and a scene and
make has a maker and a maid.
Now let's extend this paradigm further.
There's a similarity between the giver
of give and the seer of c and the maker
of make.
Those subjects are all agents.
They're all doing something,
so we call that the agent role.
There's a more passive role.
That's being played by the thing,
given the person scene and the thing made.
Those passive roles are the thematic role
of patient compare intransitive verbs
like ice sleep, you walk,
she ran or you fell.
There's another similarity,
but conventionally we think of those
roles as distinct from the agent of Mader
gave.
These people are experiencing a state,
we'll call this role the experiencer.
We might ask what's the
point of all these roles?
Why not stick with Noun cases after all?
It seems like we could explain the grammar
of I slept by saying that sleep has
one subject in the nominative case,
so I say I slept and not me slept.
The subject of see looks like it's in
the same case while the object is in the
accusative case,
so can't we stick with our concept of
nominative case nouns versus accusative
case nouns as we'll see in
the next lesson on alignment,
that distinction isn't quite so clear,
nor is it universal among languages.
We can use this concept of roles to
figure out how verbs work with their
arguments.
For now,
let's set cases side by saying that case
nouns are qualified to fill thematic
roles.
For example,
English nouns that filled the role of
patient are in the accusative or object
case, but not every noun that's in the
accusative fills the role of patient
grammatically.
They're two different things
that will suffice for preliminary
distinction between cases enrolls.
Join me next time to build on these two
as we turn to the topic of alignment.